[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous avoir
rejoints dans point de vue nous avons le
grand plaisir de commencer la semaine
avec laurent alexandre bonsoir d'être
médecin un chirurgien mais aussi
entrepreneur vous avez créé beaucoup
d'entreprises vous investissez aussi
dans d'autres et vous êtes par ailleurs
et céistes votre dernier ouvrage
jouissez jeunesse a été publié chez
lattès
puis on a le plaisir aussi de recevoir
alexandre ii vecchio bonsoir les gosses
quand vous êtes le responsable des pages
débats du figaro magazine fait aussi en
charge du figaro vox est votre livre
recomposition le nouveau monde populiste
a été publié là quelques mois maintenant
aux éditions du cerf
[Musique]
commençons avec les états d'âme ou
peut-être même le blues existentielles
des républicains ce parti est déchiré on
s'en est rendu compte lors de la crise
qui a germé lors dé la composition des
listes en paca pour les élections
régionales
en gros il ya trois positions gély
république a lié ce qu'ils veulent faire
alliance avec en marche
il ya ceux qui considèrent que non le
parti peut survivre tout seul en
présentant entre autres un président un
candidat pardon à la prochaine
présidentielle et puis il ya ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut se rapprocher du
rassemblement national tout ça n'est pas
très clair comme le rappelle de façon
cruelle mais peut-être juste christophe
castaner c'est le président du groupe en
marche à l'assemblée et il était hier
l'invité du grand jury
c'est qu'il n'ya aucune ligne claire
chez les républicains depuis plusieurs
années et ce n'est pas la faute des
manuels mâcon ça n'est pas de notre
faute si christian jacob pilote un
bateau ivre qui n'a plus de ligne
politique et parmi les signes des
difficultés existentielles des
républicains il ya bien sûr la présence
de plusieurs ministres dans le
gouvernement de jean castex comme dans
celui d'edouard philippe qui viennent de
ce parti parmi eux bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui elle est réelle rvm hba1c
blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc
mais c'est un schisme entre ceux qui
estiment que dans le fond il faut
s'allier avec le front national et qui
refuse de choisir entre le front
national et neil mac rond et ceux qui
dans le fond on la lucidité de
reconnaître que ce qui les sépare de
notre politique économique de notre
politique financière
de notre politique de sécurité aussi ne
suffit pas à créer des différences
artificiel alors un dernier point une
dernière pièce plutôt à verser au
dossier avant d'entendre le point de vue
de nos invités
c'est ce sondage publié hier par nos
confrères du parisien
quand on demande aux français à votre
avis les républicains ils sont plutôt
proches dans marche ou plutôt proche du
rassemblement national
c'est assez partagés 51 % considèrent
qu'ils sont plutôt proches en marche
contre 41% proches du rassemblement
national
ce qui est intéressant c'est que dans le
même sondage l'institut ipsos a posé la
question aux sympathisants dlr eux ils
se sentent plus proches majoritairement
dans marche à 58 % plutôt que du
rassemblement national à 33%
alexandre ii vecchio à votre avis est ce
que les républicains existeront encore
en 2023 par exemple après la prochaine
présidentielle
tout dépend de la présidentielle en vous
disant ça je crois qu'ils ont ils sont
pas totalement maître de leur destin en
réalité puisque apple d'euros font nos
configurations idéologiques clairs ils
dépendent finalement de leurs
adversaires et de l'effondrement ou pas
de l'un de leurs deux adversaires aux
conques l'euro qui sont soit le
rassemblement national soit en marre je
crois peu à l'effondrement du
rassemblement national je crois qu'il a
un socle suffisamment fort c'est un seul
corps a pu être attaqué d'ailleurs par
les républicains s'ils s'y étaient mis
tout de suite il y avait la possibilité
de recréer à rpr et de de faire flancher
marine le pen quand elle sortait de son
débat calamiteux ils l'ont pas fait donc
je crois que marine le pen et est
clairement installé pour le deuxième
tour moi c'est le pari que je ferai à
moins qu'ils aient des affaires il peut
y avoir des surprises mais je crois pas
que ça aura beaucoup d'impact sur
l'électorat du rassemblement national
par contient deux scénarios qui est
possible qu'il reste possible pour lr
c'est l'effondrement des manuels macron
ça contrairement à ce qu'on entend dans
les sondages je pense qu emmanuel macron
est très faible d'ailleurs on le voit
dans les hauts de france s'il va
chercher le bon et l'arrière banc
s'il dépêche eric dupond moretti c'est
parce qu'il craint la candidature de
xavier bertrand
et si emmanuel macron voilà n'était pas
s'effondra il pourrait y avoir un
républicain au second tour voilà le
xavier bertrand peut peut être l'un de
ceux là et ça changerait pas grand chose
idéologiquement à mon avis mais ça
assurerait la qualification des
républicains et second tour et dans ce
cas là il pourrait survivre comme un
grand sud est est finalement il prendra
la place dans marche ou comme une cd ou
allemande est donc dans ce cas là oui là
il a un avenir politique maintenant
est-ce qu'il a un avenir politique comme
partis de droite comme l'était le rp
s'adressant aux classes populaires comme
l'était le rpr autrefois je ne crois pas
voilà on sait que le gaullisme c'était
le métro à six heures le gaullisme
voilà le gaullisme ne s'en tiendra pas
je crois demain sheller je peux que je
le souhaiterais
je peux me tromper mais je crois que que
cette option n'est plus laurent
alexandre reis que l'avenir de l air est
conditionné par là la force des manuels
macron sous-entendu ils n'ont plus grand
chose à proposer par eux mêmes le
principal problème de lr aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on n'a jamais vu depuis un
siècle un parti où il ya autant de
traître lr c'est le parti des traîtres
macron a trouvé deux premiers ministres
qui ont trahi
jean castex et puis edouard philippe
bruno le maire a trahi tout le monde a
trahi donc effectivement macron a acheté
pour pas très cher
les principaux piliers dans marche donc
de devenir la puce est donc en réalité
un parti où les gens trahissent tous les
quatre matins ne peut pas exister et
celi effectivement l hétérogénéité de l
air mais en réalité le sondage présente
à l'air comme un parti dit j'ai dit
déchiré entre la tendance pro et rennes
et une tendance pro en marche
on rit theillet une troisième tendance
c'est la tendance pro maréchal à marion
maréchal dire qu'en réalité il ya une
partie importante de ce qui reste de l
air c'est la tendance bellamy
lamy est un garçon formidable mais il
est très très très très conservateur en
matière de moeurs est en réalité les
très très proches n'ont pas dû et rennes
dont il est éloigné mais de marion
maréchal en fait le problème de l air
c'est pas d'être éclaté en deux
tendances et d'être éclaté en trois
tendances une tendance en marche une
tendance marion maréchal grenouille de
bénitier anti mariage gai anti anti
droit sociétaux et puis et puis la
tendance pro pro et rennes parce qu'il
faut pas se tromper
le rn en matière de moeurs il est très à
gauche il ya une majorité de gens aux
arènes qui sont pour le mariage gay et
la pma pour tous
jordan bardella le futur président du fn
a déclaré dès juillet dernier que dès
juillet dernier que le mariage gay était
un droit acquis et qu'il était hors de
question de le supprimer
je reviens quand même à ce qu'on voit
bien qu'en réalité en réalité le r n est
plus à gauche que l air c'est bien le
problème
woody allen vous dit que il ya eu des
traîtres mais est ce que vous pensez
sincèrement qu edouard philippe est un
traître ou bruno le maire ce sont des
gens qui sont dans la filiation du pays
c'est à dire 2 centre droit libéraux
pro-européens est mal fait mais par
rapport à leur parti il va falloir
rapport à leurs idées mais moi je peux
me permettre presque de répondre parce
que j'allais lui faire cette objection
cette objection à moi je crois que c'est
pas des notes je crois qu'ils sont quand
ils rejoignent macro finalement ils sont
ils sont chez eux
tu abandonnes pour partie pour un autre
parti c'est une trahison oui mais en
fait c'est quelque chose de plus profond
que ça en réalité il y avait deux
parties à droite je disais tout à
l'heure il y avait d'un côté le le rpr
qui était à peu près pas un peu plus un
parti plus populaires qui était
effectivement le métro à six heures du
soir pour reprendre la phrase de malraux
plus souverainiste moins libérale et il
y avait le df qui était le bon voilà le
parti de valéry giscard d'estaing
européiste libéral plutôt un parti de
notables cela et c'est ce parti là qui
depuis l'ump fait c'est alain juppé qui
a créé ce parti et qui en fait était
plutôt de cette tendance là même s'il a
fait ce que jacques chirac et est
aujourd'hui c'est la tendance dominante
pourquoi pas chez les électeurs mais
chez dunod durable et les
mais pourquoi hélas pourquoi est ce que
cette droite alexandre n'arrive pas
pourquoi ce que ce parti n'arrive pas à
faire coexister ces deux courants vous
parliez du rdr il fut un temps où rpr il
y avait un gars les deux parties à la
dure et pasqua il y avait à la fois ses
gains et juppé il y avait il y avait
deux parties je crois et c'est gagné les
élections et juppé gouverner pour perdre
un peu près je vous la fais de manière
un peu problème donc là le si vous
voulez les électeurs se sont rendus
compte que la synthèse ne fonctionnait
pas du reste il y avait quand même deux
parties et aujourd'hui enfin d'autres de
ses loyers dans le grand tout qui était
qui était heller
il ya la concurrence de en marche et
surtout il ya l'émergence du
rassemblement national qui était un
parti clairement d'extrême droite avec
les excès de jean marie le pen et qui
aujourd'hui même s'il lui manque de
cadres il ya il ya bien des raisons de
craindre ce parti par son amateurisme
par un certain nombre de choses mais sur
le plan idéologique c'est un parti plus
proche de ce qui était le rpr que de
l'extrême droite traditionaliste merci à
nos internautes de réagir en direct et
bien sûr je voudrais la parole sheikh
laurent alexandre jp du nord par exemple
qui est d'accord avec vous les traîtres
sont partis il reste au contraire les
gens honorables nicole 06 c'est une
erreur de dire que l air n'a aucun
projet leur problème est qu'ils ne le
font pas connaître dans les médias ce
qui va ce qu'on a une part de
responsabilité pour tout vous dire les
responsables de l'air nous en font le
reproche assez régulièrement au figaro
et désormais nous faisons des
propositions et et vous les relayer pas
et ce qui est vrai c'est que comme on se
dit que leur chance de pouvoir les
mettre en oeuvre est encore un peu
problématique peut-être qu'on
s'intéresse pas assez à ce qu'ils
produisent les pincements ses mandats ce
qui intéresse le plus les journalistes
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir quel est le
prochain et l'eire qui va trahir vos
macron c'est ça la question je rappelle
quand même que sur la côte d'azur
estrosi et puis falco de toulon ont
trahi et son parti le mois dernier donc
on est quand même dans une phase où l
air continuent à s'appauvrir s'affaiblir
le candidat à la présidentielle qui est
xavier bertrand comme vous le savez il
est pas membre de l air il a quitté l
air donc en réalité l air il n'y a plus
rien mais alors si on regarde si on
regarde mécaniquement le rn il est
forcément autour de 30 à l'élection
présidentielle en marche et pas loin de
mélenchon va garder va garder ses
électeurs lr ne peut pas être présent
aux deuxièmes places y ait plus de
niches écologiques savoir régler
je vous de vos années dans de la mort
politique de macron pour que le centre
droit puisse avoir une chance d'exister
dilutive de maquereau est possible c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure à mon
avis à court terme et se lasser et c'est
ça c'est le romantique de macron c'est
2020 vous le voyez pas qui est sympa je
voulais qu'il faut attendre puisque je
rappelle
nos internautes que vous avez eu des
responsabilités politiques lorrains
exemple vous avez été le numéro deux du
parti d'un amas de la parti libéral
imaginez que christian jacob vous
appelle en disant j'ai besoin de vous
qu'est ce qu'est ce que je dois faire
qu'est ce que ça doit être ma stratégie
arrêtée
alors moi je serais personnellement très
pessimiste parce que je suis persuadé
c'est trop tard je suis persuadé qu
après les deux mandats de macron bardet
la gagnera la présidentielle de 2000 27
j'en ai la conviction sur un
positionnement de centre je pense que le
rn va devenir effectivement un rpr et
compte tenu du grand remplacement encore
en cours et qui fait peur à une partie
importante de d'aidé français le rn va
finir par gagner la présidentielle en
et d'ailleurs ça fait le lien avec un
sujet que nous devons aborder je crois
qu'ils aient les propositions de
beyrouth pour augmenter ses parts dans
lequel justin qui fait que vous faites
la transition parfaitement mais je vous
répondais quand même parce que le cas
ben abdellah qui était dans mon premier
livre les nouveaux enfants du siècle est
intéressant je pense que macro on peut
mourir politiquement à court terme et je
pense effectivement que jordan bardella
est un candidat peut-être beaucoup plus
solide que marion le pen pour succéder à
marie le pen et pour l'emporter
c'est d'ailleurs un enfant de
l'immigration ce qui est paradoxal pour
quelqu'un qui sera à la tête d'un parti
dix nationalistes et à qui certains font
un procès en racisme c'est quelqu'un qui
vient dé des classes populaires et qui
est assez proche de la famille le pen je
pense que c'est raté il faut le faire
pour avoir la succession mais qui en
même temps ne porte pas le nom de le pen
qui est quand même une marque mais aussi
une malédiction vous aurez remarqué
certains internautes que j'essaie de
faire parler à mes invités de l'avenir
des républicains eux il m'expliquer ce
que sera la c3 disant j'ai ce fait
preuve gel la seule qui vénère alors
personne ne veut parler de l'avenir de l
air mais elle est mort il ya au moins 31
% que deux internautes qui croient
encore alors certes c'est un peu
minoritaire mais quand on vous pose la
question sur twitter les républicains
ont-ils encore un avenir
vous répondez non à 69 %
si les lecteurs du figaro répondent non
à cette question c'est que vraiment les
carottes sont cuites pour l air alors
vous savez que les internautes
qui suivent point de vue son lecteur du
figaro mais pas tous donc c'est
peut-être un billet fait moins
pessimiste mais je pense qu'ils peuvent
gagner la présidentielle failles peuvent
gagner ce qui a aussi amusant c'est que
celui qui à mon avis le mieux les deux
qui sont mieux placés ne sont plus l air
xavier bertrand et c'est l'une de ses
qualités c'est pour ça que ça prend un
peu a choisi de se mettre à l'écart du
parti ce qui lui permet de faire une
campagne populaire semaine stream et
doit récupérer un tout petit peu des
voix des classes populaires
si les jouets et et que enfin si
emmanuel macron on était et est non
seulement comment je veux dire elle
était seule non seulement pas au second
tour mais étaient empêchés ne pouvait
pas y aller ce qui n'est pas une
hypothèse complètement folle un autre
candidat serait un candidat idéal ce
serait edouard philippe qui lui non plus
n'est pas n'est pas l'heure là pour
reprendre très clairement le centre
droit électoral drac valérie pécresse
non plus n'est plus membre des lacs des
républicains et voilà qu'elle cache de
moins en moins ses ambitions sidentielle
laurent wauquiez nos internautes qui
réagissent françoise considère que les
républicains ont un avenir à condition
d'avoir un programme qui ne soit à la
remorque de personne il faut qu'il
réapprenne à penser par eux mêmes gens
considèrent qu'avec en marche il n'y a
pas de différence et flower qui ne sont
plus crédibles avec leurs magouilles
c'est peut-être une allusion à
l'alliance qui ne dit pas son nom
entre l air est en marche dans
l'élection régionale en paca au tour de
renaud muselier et puis ce parti n'a
rien de républicain considère jean
claude aucune volonté et pas à l'écouté
du peuple
quand même alexandre de vécu vous avez
exprimé trois fois l'hypothèse selon
laquelle emmanuel macron pourrait ne pas
être au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle mais quand même
aujourd'hui il est devant marine le pen
il est au dessus de 30 % alors qu'est ce
qui vous a 25% il est au coude à coude à
part dont vous avez raison il est en
dessous d'ailleurs mené jusqu'ici il
était en dessous de marine le pen a
manqué un sondage vous avez raison et à
surmonter mais je confondais et c'était
l'argument suivant que vous
je confondais le et voilà comment le
score du premier tour si l'élection
avait lieu demain et la cote de
popularité qui était plus élevé que
celle de françois hollande ou de nicolas
sarkozy au bout de quatre ans
quinquennat avant que qu'est ce qui vous
fait dire qu'il peut s'effondrer
d'abord parce qu'on va sortir d'une
crise sanitaire que là on était dans le
coin qui là encore qu'il en coûte
et je pense que moi ça va être un
carnage économique et sociale que
emmanuel macron aura un bilan
extrêmement faible en gros on aura vu
les gilet jaune et la crise sanitaire
c'est de ça dont je me souviens mois de
d'emmanuel macro il aura même échoué je
suis pas très réformiste mais son agenda
réformistes européens il n'aura pas
réussi à le mettre en oeuvre même pas
une réforme des retraites a minima comme
l'avait fait la droite
donc je vois pas qui est bien quel bilan
il va pouvoir défendre et quelle
histoire il va pouvoir raconter france
qu'il faut raconter quand même une
histoire aux électeurs et je crois que
certes il a 30 % de popularité mais il a
aussi très grande détestation d'une
grande partie du pays on voit que la
plupart des gens ne veulent pas la
majorité des gens ne veulent plus d'un
duel macro le pen
et quand les gens ne veulent pas d'un
scénario écrit d'avancé généralement ils
se débrouillent pour faire déjouer ce
scénario c'est pour ça et que je crois à
un candidat de substitution qui moi me
risque pas de me faire rêver parce que
ce serait une sorte de demas khroubis
peut-être sans la folie sans le sang le
charisme parce que macro a aussi des
qualités sans la nouveauté mais qui
permettra au statu quo finalement de
l'emporter une nouvelle fois avant que
la crise totale m'éclate parce que je
pense que voilà elle vu l'état du pays
cela dit elle en janvier juste avant
l'élection présidentielle de 80 jusqu'à
arrêter à 60 contre 40 pour mitterrand
dans les sondages à 120 jours de
l'élection et on sait ce qu'il en est
advenu du lieu un candidat peut toujours
arriver là ça semble quand même
difficile
le contrat le second tour compte tenu de
la mort de l air le second tour annoncés
avant
avant n'a jamais eu lieu dans toutes les
parce que vous prenez chacun votre
risque vous en affirmant ça j'en suis
partant bien sûr on n'est pas sûr mais
vous avez fait ça reste une hypothèse on
était sûr de l'avenir on serait tous
riches et laurent exemple qui lui voit
emmanuel macron réélu en 2022 et jordan
bardella en 2027 nous allons voir ça ça
nous amène au deuxième sujet qui est
aussi le second cas il n'y aura pas de
troisième
c'est une note du haut commissariat au
plan dirigé désormais par françois
bayrou
une note qui ne passe pas inaperçue
puisque elle fait état c'est un constat
indéniable de la baisse de la natalité
français vous savez que ce qu'on appelle
le solde naturel c'est-à-dire la
différence entre les naissances et les
décès n'a jamais été aussi faibles il ya
que 140 et une 1000 naissances de plus
que du nombre de décès par an c'est le
niveau le plus bas depuis 1945 alors que
faire si on veut que le système français
persiste subsiste plus tôt c'est à dire
qu' on puisse continuer à financer les
retraites et la sécurité sociale et tout
notre appareil sociale eh bien il faut
avoir plus d'enfants ou accueillir des
personnes d'autres pays c'est la
préconisation du rapport
la france devra jouer sur ces deux
leviers dans des proportions
raisonnables qui garantissent le
maintien de la cohésion nationale
d'accord pas d'accord laurent alexandre
françois bayrou a tout à fait raison
le débat est obscurci parce que on a
fait peur aux français avec le grand
emplacement
la réalité c'est que la france se
métisse très très très rapidement parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'immigrés parce que
les français entre guillemets de souche
ne font plus de bébés ils font plus de
bébés parce que les occidentaux
globalement au fond de moins en moins de
bébés et mais aujourd'hui s'est aggravée
avec la crise du coc vide mais surtout
par la présence très forte d'un courant
collapse aux log écologistes
d'ayatollahs verts qui conseille de ne
pas faire d'enfant à la jeunesse on a vu
yves cochet
on a vu barreau l'astrophysicien
écologistes expliqué que les français
les jeunes français devait ne pas faire
de bébé pour laisser de la place aux
immigrés et pour laisser de la place aux
africains pour qu'ils puissent venir en
plus grand nombre dans dans l'hexagone
donc tous militent pour ce que décrit
berrou arrivent les français d'origine
ne font plus de bébés les jeunes on leur
explique qu'ils professent pas faire de
bébé et puis on laisse les frontières
ouvertes donc on a effectivement à la
fin une accélération du grand
remplacement
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui comme les
français d'origine ne font plus de bébés
le grand remplacement il est inévitable
alors on peut le regretter et l'extrême
droite le regrette mais il est
inévitable dire la france va être
massivement métissé dans les décennies
qui viennent
et quand on regarde l'origine des
naissances elles sont aujourd'hui dans
de plus en plus de villes en france
d'origine extra-européenne donc le
métissage la france il va s'accélérer il
va s'accélérer puisque les français ne
font plus de bébés c'est l'injonction
des écologistes pour laisser la place
aux immigrés africains comme dit cochet
comme c'est donc nous allons avoir un
grand mouvement il faut l'assumer et il
faut pas diaboliser le grand
remplacement le grand remplacement il
est là c'est une réalité il faut
l'accompagner il faut l'assumer et
berrou nous dit faut faire plus de bébés
mais on va pas faire plus de bp puisque
toute la journée on explique que la fin
du monde arrive donc les français vont
pas faire deux bébés dans une ambiance
apocalyptique telle qu'on la connaît
donc on va bien être obligé on doit bien
être obligé de faire appel à
l'immigration
ça va a heurté bien sûr les
nationalistes mais c'est inévitable
non rien n'est rien était inévitable moi
je me bats au delà de cette question là
contre l'idée qui a qu'une seule
politique possible je crois que c'est
pas le cas d'ailleurs on a vu on a vu
des gens qui avaient une autre politique
gagner dans d'autres pays faire des
choses qu'on aurait cru pas possible ce
qui nous expliquait il n'y a pas si
longtemps qu'il y avait une dette
c'était terrible et ses dépenses
aujourd'hui à tour de bras peut-être
avec des conséquences délétères parce
qu'on voit trop loin dans quelques
années mais en tout cas c'est pas vrai
il n'y a jamais qu'une seule politique
possible d'ailleurs c'était pas notre
politique
jusqu'à peu en avait une politique
familiale et efficace qui faisait qu'on
était le pays et je crois que malgré
tout il demeure d'europe qui fait le
plus d'enfants malgré tout l'hiver
démographique européen existe depuis
longtemps mais en france il existe que
depuis quelques années plus
particulièrement depuis le quinquennat
hollande qui a abandonné notre politique
familiale donc nous faisons une une
politique familiale est on pour un jour
les gens les écologistes la volonté de
la taxe écologique et s'opposeront je
vais i'm here i am on n'est pas obligé
au fait de la politique aussi avec les
électeurs donc il ya un guichet des
écologistes mais il ya aussi les
électeurs on peut peut-être essayer de
les convaincre que oui il faut il faut
faire des enfants et les bêtes dans les
conditions parce que je crois que si les
gens font pas d'enfant c'est
qu'effectivement ils ont une vision
sombre de l'avenir et il est dans une
condition rejetée qui leur permet
d'avoir une espérance je devais pas
faire d'abou thing je ne vais pas citer
de noms bien évidemment mais ce qui me
frappe beaucoup c'est que parmi les
nationalistes de droite
la plupart des jeunes ne font pas
d'enfants font 0 enfants souvent ou un
enfant
donc en réalité même les gens qui
défendent une politique anti grand
remplacement
ils font pas de gauche donc je dis à ces
gens qui s'opposent aux grands
emplacements vous faites pas de gosses
donc le grand emplacement il est
inévitable et si vous n'êtes pas content
vous n'avez qu'à faire des gamins et ce
n'est pas le cas les nationalistes et
les identités se mêlent ils font pas
d'enfant l'ocam il ya un moment où il ya
un problème de cohérence chez les
nationalistes l'immigration et je pense
pour l'instant emmanuel macron est
président de la république il n'a pas
d'enfant
la plupart des apn
des papiers très intéressant sur la
plupart des leaders européens plutôt de
centre droit ou de centre-gauche qui
n'avait pas d'enfant donc je suis pas
sûr que les je crois que viktor orban a
cinq ou six enfants donc je sais pas je
devais nationalistes français mais je ne
connais pas la vie privée des uns et des
autres exemples mais l'exemple du grand
dimension puisqu'il a fait zéro bd je
n'en suis pas sûr ensuite si si la fête
de rebaisser sur wii donnent le oui non
je suis donc je suis pas sûr qu'on les
hait ce coup je suis alors si c'est un
scoop il a pas fais super je ne connais
pas la vie privée des identitaires et
des nationalistes européens
on connaissait la effectivement de ceux
qui sont au pouvoir et pour le coup il
faut pas il faut pas beaucoup d'enfants
dans sur l'immigration je crois pas que
ça peut être une une solution puisque
faire des enfants elle était en voie qu
à quoi on pourquoi l'europe ou bayrou
propose ça parce que pour sauver notre
système social
en réalité or moi je ne suis pas du tout
sûr que ça sauve notre système social
alors certes à court terme la baisse de
la natalité fait qu'on a moins d'actifs
mais est ce que faire venir des gens de
l'immigration est ce que ce serait
forcément plus d'emplois et plus
d'actifs j'en suis patient faut quand
même rappeler aux gens que il ya deux
fois plus de chômage dans les
populations immigrées
donc ça me paraît pas être et pour le
coup on a encore pas mal d'actifs en
france pour fabriquer des robes qui je
vous interromps faut créer les
conditions plein emploi et on aura plus
de problème le dépassement passionnant
la vie de nos internautes aussi donc je
vous les donne et après je repasse la
parole évidemment à nos deux invités
l'immigration est elle la solution à la
baisse de la démographie française de la
démographie je dis bien c'est non à 85%
ce qu'il nous faut c'est une vraie
politique nataliste et en même temps
arrêter l'immigration surtout illégal
quand ce dernier col 06 il faudrait une
politique nataliste renchérit chardon
bleu avec davantage d aide pour les
familles dont les enfants paieront les
retraites des célibataires et
c'est ce point de vue de baxi
l'immigration est la seule solution la
france ne risque pas d'en avoir et toto
l'immigration est la seule solution
qu'on le veuille ou non
laurent alexandre sur ce point que vient
de deux souligné alexandre de vecchio
les chiffres en tout cas d'avant la
crise du coc vite ses taux de chômage
chez les immigrés d'origine
extra-européenne 24% contre un peu moins
de neuf chez chez les français donc ce
n'est pas cette immigration telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui savate et
lillers vous savez très bien qu'en
matière d'immigration on est en plein
délire et en plaine un v6 lité cognitive
puisque la france aujourd'hui exporte
ses bac + 5 vers les états unis la
californie la city et elle importe des
bacs -5 donc la france exporte des
travailleurs ultra qualifiés nécessaires
dans l'économie de la connaissance et
alain portes des cas des travailleurs
ultra sous qualifiés dont beaucoup vont
finir au chômage donc la politique
actuelle elle est absurde
dire que la france fait venir sur son
seul aujourd'hui des gens qui n'ont pas
leur place dans l'économie de la
connaissance et qui demain seront
marginalisés malheureux dans une
économie ultra complexes comme la
nouvelle économie est en train de 2,2 de
se développer
donc si nous étions rationnelle si les
nationalistes et et rationnels ils
pousseraient le pousserait les jeunes
français à faire des bébés
au lieu d'écouter les écologistes et les
ayatollahs verts
et puis on choisirait une immigration
choisie justement en faisant venir des
travailleurs qualifiés et puis par
ailleurs on éviterait que les français
les plus qualifiés ne quitte la france
on a vu à quel point c'est l'exemple
plus magnifique
la france s'est privé d'un prix nobel
puisque quand en mi 2012
madame charpentier prix nobel de l'année
dernière a voulu rentrer en france le
gouvernement
le cnrs et l'institut pasteur lui ont
fait un bras d'honneur et ont refusé de
le trouver un poste
et donc elle est restée en allemagne
madame charpentier prix nobel parce que
la france considérait que ça ne sert à
rien d'avoir des savants de très très
haut niveau
donc on vous
la névrose française qui est de faire
partir les bons comme madame charpentier
de refuser de les faire revenir la
france est le seul pays au monde a
envoyée à l'extérieur ces prix nobel le
seul pays au monde tout le monde
s'arrache les prix nobel sauf la france
donc la france fait partir les bons
esprits elle fait venir des gens qui
finissent au chômage donc là il ya une
névrose française qu'il faut corriger je
suis d'accord avec l'ex ans oui on dit
on dit la même chose alors vous vous
alignez les nationales et sans pointer
du doigt je sais pas si je suis
nationaliste on sait tous qu'on va
traiter en tout cas pas nationaliste
béni bellicisme et oui la ga rien contre
la nation au contraire je suis patriote
et souverainistes mais on dit on dit
exactement la même chose ne pas faire
partir les bons ne pas accueillir des
gens qui font qu'on ne pourra pas
intégrer à qui on ne pourra pas de
travail donc et et revenir à une
politique familiale qui fonctionnait non
moi je pense qu'il ya deux poids en
revenir à une politique familiale qui
fonctionnait on était quand même le pays
qui avait le plus de deux bébés en
europe et ensuite créer un cercle
vertueux en réalité aujourd'hui
pour ce qui est du système social si on
était en situation de poing plein emploi
il y aurait pas de problème je souligne
il ya suffisamment d'actifs pour faire
que comprenait un système social
efficace le problème c'est qu'il ya trop
de chômage donc mettre enfin faire une
politique
enfin tourner vers l'emploi et ça crée
un double cercle vertueux un cercle
vertueux économique mais ça me donnera
aussi du moral aux français
et quand les gens ont le moral ont un
avenir généralement ils font plus
d'enfants
merci beaucoup à tous les deux
souhaitons que vous ayez raison fischer
alexandre je laisse le mot de la fin à
pm 75 sur internet qui répond en disant
il faudrait déjà assimilé l'immigration
passé avant d'envisager une nouvelle et
quelque chose me dit que c'est un sujet
dont nous reparlerons
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis et à demain
bonsoir
[Musique]